I'm Maddie thanks thank you uh really
excited to to be here
um I this is the last talk before lunch
I know how those go so we'll try to get
you out of here soon enough uh but until
then we'll talk about play therapy what
it is uh how we built an app using NLP
machine learning to provide mental
health support to parents and families
and uh you know how just five minutes a
day can bring so much joy to families
right we'll dive into the architecture
of happy pillar we'll talk about all of
its Tech components and then we'll also
you know leave room for for some
questions so I have a pretty traditional
Tech background
um I studied math and computer science I
spent my entire career in product and
Engineering I built uh intelligent
search products information retrieval
systems uh focused a lot on NLP
specifically conversational AI I worked
at startups did Consulting for a little
bit uh and then I just kind of missed
the chaos of a startup and and building
so I joined a conversational AI company
which is where I'm at Scott and it's
also where I met my co-founder Sam she
was heading up customer success at the
time this was about three years ago so
right before the pandemic and this was
also around the time that I moved to
Texas to be closer to my family I am not
a you know Sam likes to say I'm not a
child Haver any of you here have kids
okay wow lots and lots of parents that's
great
um uh yeah so I'm not a child however I
have a sister though she has a son so I
enjoy spending a lot of time with my
nephew so Sam and I just became friends
she's really easy to get along with I
wish you were here so you can meet her
um and we started talking about the
challenges of of parenting and because I
was like living closer to my sister and
spending time with my nephew I also got
to see up front the challenges of of
parenting especially during a pandemic
so Sam was facing some similar issues
with her kid Winston
um and she did something called
parent-child interaction therapy it's
talk based it's play-based it's
non-invasive and it worked amazingly
well for her right she likes to talk
about how the results were like magic
but the thing is it was hella expensive
and it was incredibly hard to access and
the thing is it's not a unique problem
young children right now are facing a
mental health crisis there's one in five
kids sadly that have some kind of mental
emotional or behavioral disorder
um and it's been around for a while but
things have certainly gotten worse
during the pandemic because of covid and
because of the chaos and unrest in kids
lives
um
you know it wasn't necessarily easy for
me growing up as a gay kid and also as a
child of immigrants and as easy as you
know as not easy as that was sometimes
it's way harder for kids now
going through all of this chaos gun
violence and the lack of safety in our
schools I know we're all kind of
thinking about Nashville but my nephew
just said to me a couple of days ago
that he was kind of getting sick of uh
you know the school shooting drills and
he was like you know I just don't want
to do this stuff anymore you know when
is the real thing going to happen is the
real thing going to happen
he's eight so obviously he doesn't fully
understand what that means but I I can't
imagine that other kids aren't thinking
this that other parents aren't
necessarily worried about something like
this so gun violence and the pandemic
and other stressful things definitely
changed the way that we parent
um
and you know the solution is behavioral
therapy you know it's unanimously
recommended by experts it's non-invasive
it can be play-based or talk based
um but there are a few problems with it
it's very inaccessible
um it's very expensive Sam was spending
close to a thousand dollars a month and
even if you can afford something like
that not everyone uh has the time to
take out like you know an hour or two a
week multiple hours going to therapy uh
doing therapy with their kids and even
if you have the time and the money to do
that nearly every clinician these days
has a wait list of over two years
um so you know those are those are
definitely some problems here even
though this is incredibly effective
so you know we're at you know at the
Golden Age of AI everyone is doing
incredible things just at this venue you
have Jasper and I think in a little
while you'd be speaking to Ron green
um doing you know companies doing
incredible things with generative AI
that actually move the needle on helping
companies people and teams right so we
wanted to
um find a solution to this that focused
on the accessibility on making this
scalable using a one-to-many
relationship with therapists and we
wanted to make it affordable so we
decided to build an AI human-powered
platform that provides instant access to
behavioral therapy and I know what
you're thinking you know we're all
probably thinking the same thing Ai and
mental health like what chatbot
therapists everything that could
potentially go wrong can go wrong
um everyone in this room here knows
about generative AI when unchecked can
can be particularly damaging especially
when it comes to mental health
um but you know so we spent a lot of
time thinking about the right kind of
approach and the way that play therapy
works is this
um you see a therapist they onboard you
onto the skills of of how to do this
kind of therapy uh they ask you to spend
five minutes a day with your kid five
minutes of play uninterrupted where the
kid leads the play and they give you
certain guidelines to follow and then
once a week they watch you interact with
your kid and they provide feedback
and the guidelines are this
so you're supposed to narrate their
behavior 10 times so I can say something
like I see that some of you are taking
notes I see that some of you are
watching me talk about therapy uh and
you're supposed to do that 10 times
you're supposed to celebrate their
behavior 10 times so you might say
something like uh Scott thank you for
being so generous with your time and
just being a great product manager when
we work together right uh I you know
we're supposed to imitate their play and
we're supposed to Echo back what they
say so you might say something like if
you you know if your kid says
um my car is going really fast so you
might say something like yeah your car
really is zooming right and within these
five minutes you're not supposed to ask
questions you're not supposed to give
commands or do any kind of negative talk
or criticism it sounds kind of
sophomoric like very simplistic but it's
been around since the 1940s it has tons
of evidence and research behind it and
when you perform these guidelines
consistently it decreases is Tantrums
decreases meltdowns helps with you know
issues following directions negotiation
before bedtime all of these things that
kids typically face
and a therapist gives you feedback once
a week they're like okay well you've
celebrated your kids Behavior seven
times why don't you try to get that up
to 10. you've asked five questions and
here's how you can rephrase your
questions as statements
and so what we're doing at happy pillar
is something similar we do have an
in-house therapist we have a clinical
Advisory board that created the program
and methodology behind happy pillar they
instruct you on how to do this kind of
therapy
and then instead of the therapist
listening to you interact with your kid
once a week we record the interaction
every time you play with your kid every
time you hit record we Analyze That and
provide you feedback on how well you did
the feedback is pre-vetted by a
therapist so it's therapist-led and
vetted even though we are using NLP and
and recommender systems which we'll get
into in a little bit but the feedback is
instantaneous it's 24 7. therapy is not
rationed in any way and you could use it
whenever you want you know and the time
commitment is five minutes a day
so let's talk a little bit about the
architecture of happy pillar the primary
user interface is a mobile application
that's how users interact with the app
we use flutter to support both iOS and
Google Play how many of you have like
experienced submitting to the app store
or or Google play or been working on
mobile apps okay yeah when you've done
Enterprise for so long or B2B Enterprise
for so long you kind of forget how
complicated it can be to like submit to
the App Store and work on Google Play
compliance and App Store compliance so
yeah if you're if you're building apps
I'd say get started with the submission
process right away anything to do with
payments or in-app purchases can be
pretty pretty intense and complicated
so we record on the mobile app the
recordings are anonymized and we'll talk
about Security in a little bit they're
then sent to the back end in Friends
Engine so the inference engine sits
behind an elastic load balancer the load
balancer you know the main purpose is
like we all know what it does it takes a
look at the incoming requests that
distributes them across a fleet of
inference engines so we have multiple
instances of that
um the inference engine is is exposed
using a rest API we built that using
fast API in Python even though I know
that Ian wasn't a big fan of of python
earlier it's it works um and uh in the
database we record we send some of the
recordings which are encrypted uh we
also store things like a happy score
which is basically a snapshot of how
well you did during the therapy session
with your kid
um uh and and things like that so let's
talk a little bit about the inference
engine there's multiple components to
this it has multiple modules the first
component is the sdt speech to text it
has two responsibilities the first is to
convert the speech into text
and we use uh whisper for sdt we
experimented with a bunch of tools
whisper was was pretty good
and the second responsibility is
diarization so diarization essentially
means we're trying to identify the adult
speaker and the child speaker and the
reason we do this is because we wanna
only analyze the adult speech we really
try not to do anything with the child
speech at all another kind of thing that
we're keeping like being mindful of for
security reasons
um we thought that it would be kind of
easy to do diarization and it is for the
most part we use speech brain for that
but we'll get into some of the
challenges and approaches we took in a
little bit the second component is the
sentence classifier
so remember all of the things you're
supposed to do and not supposed to do we
call them nice skills and not now skills
um we passed them through a sentence
classifier we feed the adult utterances
to it it identifies the intents and
entities we use you know a combination
of Open Source nlu some homegrown
technology and they're built on top of
llms
for one of the skills specifically for
Echo we use sentence similarities
specifically we use semantic textual
similarity to see how similar the the
two phrases are so that's a little bit
about the inference engine
all of the utterances or all of the
recordings pass through the sdt then the
sentence classifier then sentence you
know similarity for Echoes then we
analyze we generate some feedback and we
send that back to the user
so overall here's you know a high level
process flow we instruct our users on
how to conduct this kind of therapy
session with your kid we record the
interaction
um convert it into text analyze it and
then give them a feedback almost
instantaneously within five to six
seconds
uh so yeah let's talk about all of these
uh components the first thing we do is
we instruct parents within the app just
like a therapist would in a therapy
session we make all of the instructions
kind of interactive and you know we use
short form content Bitesize videos
we walk you through what play therapy is
how to you know what nice skills are how
to like perform each of the the
components of a nice skill and a not now
skill we experimented with this we had
long form content before but we very
quickly got some user feedback that was
like hey this is too long I don't know
if I can watch a 10 minute video on how
to do this and then do therapy with my
kid at the end of like uh you know a
full day's worth work you know no one
really wants to watch
a lecture on therapy so short form
content really worked interactive
content where you're nudged to do some
practice sessions you get some quizzes
that you could do either with voice or
text really helps with engagement
recording is pretty simple users just
kind of hit record within the app they
use their phones to record it we will
expand into you know iPads and other
devices soon but right now I think
phones work just fine
Okay so
and then we die rise right so we use
um
speech brain
um for diarization it's an open source
technology it works great so initially
we thought meeting transcription
Services what they do is essentially
like identify different adult speakers
in a room and they assign you know they
tag each adult and they can even you
know assign to Do's they do like a
summary it's great and so we were like
okay well it must be so much easier
trying to identify an adult and a child
because they sound so different but one
of the issues that we immediately ran
into was that a child and a female
speaker can sound pretty similar
um so we were like okay well that's not
really going to work so we tried to look
at something like recording like
requiring users to record a voice note a
sample so then we can tag that as the
adult and that's kind of frictiony you
know not everyone wants to like record a
voice sample before they can even get
through the onboarding flow so right now
we're using a combination of something
called format frequencies which looks at
the frequency of the adult and the child
speaker children typically have higher
frequencies they have greater temporal
and spectral variability than adults it
works I would say it's about like 80 to
85 percent accurate in you know in our
experience so we're trying to experiment
with other approaches that would be more
accurate so if any of you have
experience with diarization or have any
kind of advice for me would love to hear
it
um oh I meant to say that we spoke with
our friends at avoma which is a meeting
transcription service so we looked at
tools like avoma speech brain works
really well for us uh one of the things
that Aroma does is that they follow a a
a buffet-like approach where they look
at different tools and they use
different tools so they're like you know
this particular tool is better when it
comes to Accents and this vendor is
better when it comes to things like
noise so we're currently trying to use
multiple tools as opposed to just like a
one solution fits all
the next thing we do is convert it to
text uh we use whisper it works pretty
well with our diarization techniques the
way that we do this is we chop up our
recordings into multiple segments so we
have zero to ten seconds we have 11 to
20 and so forth and each segment is kind
of tagged with who the speaker is or who
the speakers are and whether that's
adult or child
um and then we parse through the
segments and then we send it to our
sentence classifier to analyze
so at this phase
um you know sentence classification what
we do is we try to identify the intents
and extract any kind of applicable
entities the intents are narration
celebration for Echo we use sentence
similarities so I'll talk about that in
a little bit questions commands negative
talk are all intents we don't really
have to deal with entities too much but
when we do we use Spacey
um I'm sure everyone here is familiar
with Spacey also open source also great
um and for semantic textual similarity
for Echo we try to calculate how similar
the two sentences are so we convert the
text into
embeddings that capture semantic
information and we try to see how how
close and distance the two sentences are
for this we use expert which is a a
sentence Transformer
and you know it works it works pretty
great so after we get the analysis we
try to capture how many narrations you
did we give you basically a count of all
of it and then we sent it to you know
the feedback engine uh feedback is
produced in two ways we display like an
actual readout of how many narrations
celebrations Echoes questions Etc that
you did and then we also kind of
aggregate that and calculate a score
it's called a happy score and it's a
snapshot of how well you did and you
have access to historical happy scores
and were able to like bubble up some
really interesting insights as you keep
using the app it gets even more
personalized and tailored to your use
case so let's say you and your kid want
it to work on Tantrums or managing big
feelings you can kind of see how well
you're doing look at your progress over
time and then once you're done with that
you can move on to uh another thing that
you want to work on together
so let's take a look at what this looks
like within the app
um
we tell you how to do each of these
rituals
imitation you know celebration like we
talked about we tell you how you can
avoid asking questions which is you know
pretty hard because it's we ask kids so
many questions during the day
criticism commands
you can watch videos
so that's a little bit about the flow
and here's what the feedback looks like
specifically here's the happy score
which is a snapshot of your performance
and a breakdown of how you did
and
you know we're currently working on on
providing personalized recommendations
something that's more actionable for
each parent unit we use a combination of
collaborative filtering and
content-based recommendations to provide
these and right now you know we're
trying to find the right balance between
anonymizing the data and having access
to enough attributes so that we could
build a more effective and accurate
collaborative filtering system
um you know it's a fine balance to tread
we certainly want to be mindful of
security here but we do want to surface
recommendations like you've asked seven
questions here's exactly how you know
Samantha you can rephrase your questions
as statements or you know I've seen that
you've done five celebrations but there
really were other opportunities within
this transcript as you can see here to
do more celebrations so we want this to
be like an Interactive Learning Journey
that you do with with your kids
but we're in the process of building out
our recommendation engine right now so
again if you have any thoughts on
you know how to build something that's
uh you know effective collaborative
engine that doesn't require using too
much of our parents data I would love to
hear it
um one of the things that we found so we
started happy pillar about a year ago in
February of 2022. we were still working
at this conversational AI company with
Scott and Sam Sam and I quit our jobs in
may we worked evenings and weekends it
was hard but it was so much fun
um and we found out right away that we
don't have access to a lot of seed data
you know you don't have publicly
available parent-child interaction data
that's a great thing but it also meant
that we
had to do a lot of building from scratch
we had to start collecting data from
scratch and we also found out that hey
you know why don't we just build an MVP
right away ship it out to like people
that we know or network and get them to
use it and collect data that way right
and we posted on one Facebook mom group
Facebook mom groups are so incredibly
loyal and engaged I had no idea I'm not
even on Facebook but Sam posted and I
think within a couple of hours we got
like 60 people saying yeah my kid is a
monster like I would love to use this
kind of thing like how can I get on it
right away uh and within two hours our
first Alpha was was was filled already
we had people using it we use that data
to make our models better but we also
got their feedback to make the app
itself better we released our second
Alpha in March uh sorry in April same
thing we posted in a Facebook mom group
a different one
we had 70 people wanting to use it right
away we got their data we made the
models better
um yeah and over the course of the next
few months we released a private beta
and then a public beta as well we've had
over 3 000 downloads so far pretty good
engagement rate and over 13 000 minutes
of proprietary data that made our models
a lot better we use you know like I said
large-scale language models so we do a
fair bit of prompt engineering as well
which you know I'm glad everyone's
talking about prompt engineering right
now it's it's great to see that
everyone's like super interested in it
um it's it's crucial to like tweak your
prompts to make sure that they're as
succinct as and as specific as possible
um so we so we do a lot of that we also
built an internal tool that we kind of
exposed to our clinical advisory team
they kind of use our tool to like work
on the prompt engineering themselves so
it's kind of it's it's it's really great
to have subject matter experts do the
prompt engineering for you rather than
having Engineers do it because they can
you know work on the prompt and Chloe
our in-house therapist will listen to
transcripts she'll manually code the
utterances herself and she's like okay
well here's my feedback and readout and
then she'll compare that to our models
and we try to make sure that they're as
close to each other as possible
um thanks to like the data that we have
um we've we match therapist accuracy
which is at about 86 percent and you
know we're confident that as we continue
to like keep building the app out as we
collect more data you know we'll try to
make that even more accurate
so security is pretty top of mind for
happy pillar we were kind of shocked to
know that mental health apps are not
regulated at all
um you know obviously you have to think
of gdpr compliancy and things like that
but like they're not regulated in a way
that you think that they would be but we
didn't want that to like stop us from
treating these transcripts like private
medical records and that's what we do
um we scrub all pii we anonymize the
data right after we're done recording on
the user's phone uh by the time it hits
our HIPAA compliance servers it's
scrubbed and anonymized
um and when we're communicating between
the back end and front end TLS https is
used so that's how we kind of encrypt
data in motion and parts of it are
definitely encrypted when they're stored
in our database and and the things that
we store are just happy scores
um historical progress related related
information things that parents actually
want to come back to so that's how we
encrypt data at rest we follow soc2
compliance standards which I'm sure
we're all familiar with industry leading
practices but one thing we're really
proud of is orca it's an independent
digital Health assessment review board
they do a very thorough check in review
of your app or Services
um you know compliance uh and and they
look at Safety and Security and things
like that so we passed it so that felt
good and I think you know things like
the kids safe seal mom's Choice kind of
tell other parents that we're a safe app
to use
um so parent-child interaction and play
therapy is our Focus right now we
support kids age two to seven but
there's definitely lots of things that
we can do with the platform that we
currently have and we have plans to
expand into we built kind of a neutral
third-party AI engine that can analyze
any two or multiple person conversation
and provide feedback on that we want to
expand into couples therapy there's a
five minute couples version of this
which I'm excited to try out
um
do you want to use it like I I would
love to test it out with you
yeah it's based off of John gottman's uh
uh
like thing of deposits and withdrawals
and ideally like you make deposits in
your you know I don't want to get too
into this but like you make certain
deposits in your relationship you do
withdrawals and I think you're supposed
to do like 20 deposits for every one
withdrawal you do or something like that
right so we want to to see how we could
use John gottman's method
um within the happy pillar umbrella um
and and we want to do that later this
year early next year so we'll keep you
posted uh but there's like multiple
modules that we can offer older kids too
kids aged eight and up there's tons of
teens like working on things like social
media addiction social isolation so we
want to provide CBT and DBT for older
kids as well uh you know speech therapy
uh perhaps happy pillar as like a
workflow augmentation tool but as as
we're doing this really our North Star
and Scott is one of the best product
managers I know who loves to talk about
North star's product
um is is it responsive responsive to the
community that we're building for you
know we want to expand into Spanish
because we have lots of parents that
speak Spanish in their households but
it's not as simple as just adding a
Spanish language pipeline which you know
we can all do within a day or two right
uh it's more than that
um praise wasn't a big thing for me and
my household growing up and it's not
praise Works differently in different
cultures right so we want to be
culturally inclusive and mindful of that
and we want to contract with the right
therapist and linguists to offer Spanish
within happy pillar or Hindi or Tagalog
or something like that
um and another North Star is is it
leading to positive outcomes for the
people using it and if we think that you
know expanding into something like
speech therapy or adding Maybe
you know multiple features like you know
a particular feature to pcit right now
is going to lead to positive outcomes
and that's a feature that we definitely
want to work on and I have to say I mean
I know that we all like sit through like
bug grooming sessions and feature
sessions
um
and we've done this for B2B Enterprise
and you know they're fine they're
productive whatever
but some of the customer grooming
sessions at happy pillar are so fun
because we get emails like hey here are
all of the things that are wrong with
your app I can't use it I can't get into
it there's a microphone issue but then
one customer included a picture of his
kid and was like but you know thank you
for helping her and I was like like
this is so cool like it's amazing to get
this kind of customer feedback so yeah
overall it's been it's been fun and uh I
can't wait to continue the conversation
with all of you thank you
thank you